we have doubled the donesies here on the
set double the done geez right here the
author's Tony and now Lauren Dungey here
on the program good to see you Lauren
it's great to be here good to have you
back actually I should say you were here
last year talking about a couple couple
of their children's books now we chose
you is the newest book for you to put in
front of all the parents and all the
kids and certainly all the adoptive
parents and adopted children's is about
adoption family and forever love why did
you choose this subject I know the
answer but I figured I'll just throw it
out to you right away Lauren you know
there's not a lot of material available
when it comes to adoption and we wanted
to support the adoptive parents and
those that are even considering adoption
and we wanted to write a story that
children could relate to and adults as
well and many parents have difficulty
talking about adoption but it's a
natural thing it's a beautiful thing and
you know families are created many
different ways adoption being one of
them and we told that story through the
eyes of little Calvin who is exploring
his own adoption journey he comes home
from school with a project and he wants
to hear about his story about adoption
and where he came from and most
importantly he wants to know that he's
loved
he was planned for he was prayed for and
it's just forever home
and you guys have seven adopted child we
do we have seven children at home
they're all adopted and we have an
eighth one that will soon join the crew
within a month no kidding no kidding
from we're here in the United States
alright he's been with us for about five
months okay I want to ask you a question
that that may sound off but I think many
people might be thinking why why why
adopt a child and certainly if you've
already got seven of them we love
children we really do we have a passion
for them we bill all children deserve a
forever home and a loving home and we
we're in the place now that we can
provide that for them we can we have the
resources we have the time
we have the love and we went to open our
home to children Tony that's one of the
things that we found out in 1999
in Tampa at that time in Florida and it
still exists there was a shortage of
adoptive parents a shortage of foster
parents and there were kids who were in
group homes and kids waiting to be
adopted and I didn't realize that you
know you you hear the stories of people
waiting years or going to foreign
countries but I know in Florida there
are a lot of kids who need homes so when
you say in 1999 you heard this well that
was we have an 18 year old now sure that
was our beginning of our journey in
Florida looking at adoption and Lauren
and Tony Dungy here on the Rich Eisen
show in we chose you in this in this
book what are you hoping that people get
out of something from this here Lauren
we hope that people will be inspired
with adoption and and something that
they're thinking about doing that they
will be encouraged to adopt and for
those that who are adopted or have
children in their families that are
adopted that they're celebrating
adoption it's a beautiful thing and we
enjoy it and we probably will adopt more
and I think the message to the kids too
is if you're adopted it's not that your
mom didn't want you or your parents
didn't want you a lot of circumstances
could lead into that but you were taken
by someone who loved you and God placed
you in a place where you're supposed to
be bright and you know one of the things
I love about doing the show is talking
about subjects that may not have that
clearly don't have anything to do with
sports but this is life sports is part
of life is part of pop culture it's part
of life as well and so there might be
many people out there watching and
listening and seeing you guys and
listening to your story do you have any
suggestions on how to handle informing a
child that he or she has been adopted
starting at an early age and a lot of
people think there's the magic age
there may be a teenager or something but
it's important to tell it should be just
a natural thing when you're reading
stories you're having conversations and
mention it to the child and it just
becomes a very natural thing and they
don't feel that there's something
secretive about adoption it's just one
of God's ways of putting families
together
is is that part of we chose you that is
one of the messages in the story would
this be a book in which it would be
helpful that if the if the information
has just been told to follow up with the
book like this absolutely we really
would like to see more stories out there
about adoption with children sometimes
their stories and they use animals we
all love animals sure that I think
children relate to those that they see
that look like them you have thoughts on
the subject Tony yeah no very much so
that Calvin is trying to figure out his
story and it's different from his
classmates but he gets reassured by his
parents that know that this is how God
planned to bring you into our family
other people get brought in different
ways but we are blessed to have you and
we love you and it's we're a special
family and so just telling the kids that
that yes maybe you didn't come from
mom's stomach like the other kids did
but you're still special to us and
that's all kids need to know and do you
have any advice other than go for it do
it to people who are thinking of
becoming adoptive parents give any
advice said we need you number one and
so if you have a thought and you feel
it's something you may want to do
investigate it and go go check it out
and it's not that hard I can say that
it's definitely not that hard and it's
very much needed in the country today
and what about any apprehensions that
you guys may have had together because
again it's it's you you have such a
beautiful story here and a united front
when we're talking about it right here
did you guys have any questions about it
back in 1999 when you talk about you
want to make sure that
child is loved and feel special but it's
just like having your own biological
children you would do the same thing and
that's just a given security and love
and that's what that's all they really
want and I'm mandated to ask this
question as well knowing him as well as
I do when you were beginning to have
young small children did SAP ever
babysit the 99 of course he did yeah he
was down the street he's one of my
favorite people Warren he's just he's
quite something and so okay so it's
great having you on like this is like a
tradition yeah thank you essentially
because last year you came on for Maria
fines coverage and Austen plays fair got
another book coming out in August about
you want to give me a preview once a
person finds forgiveness and it's a
story about all children need to learn
how to forgive and then hold that in and
this little boy Carson has some issues
that he has to deal with and he has to
learn how to forgive other people what
grades did you teach in elementary I
taught sixth grade sixth grade entry my
mother was a kindergarten teacher first
in second grade a little bit too and my
dad was a was a French teacher college
adviser I'm from to New York City public
school education so we're out of the
classroom but we're not really removed
because we visit every week we're
reading to the kids title one schools in
Tampa Tampa for us okay it's been fun
and awesome well and where do you guys
head next what's on your tour next well
that's great and then when do you get
cracking
NBC we you know you don't you don't do
the premium you tap the top free
preseason we start out regular season
the Thursday night will be in Chicago
that's gonna be him that is Hana beer
yeah it'd be awesome yeah a little
Packers Bears rivalry to kick it all off
that is gonna be great yeah and then
Pittsburgh New England what
i pound at the table for for the bet
that i love that first opening Sunday
night game yeah that's gonna be
somewhere we're very excited we've got a
great schedule but you'll be in Chicago
be in Chicago and then you guys will be
in parts unknown Tom thanks for coming
on the show you guys are welcome anytime
again Tony and Lauren Dungey I'm holding
up the book right here we chose you
check it out we're all books are sold
okay Lauren Dungey has joined us here on
the Rich Eisen show all the radio
audience is away let's take a look at
some of these photographs I think this
is from your Twitter account Tony this
is it right there what are we looking at
here Lauren what are we looking at here
okay this is and what what are we
looking at this sprint triathlon so this
is the ride portion and it's a 13 mile
ride that we do after swimming in the
open water
okay so you've already swam already swim
okay and that was the challenge and
where was this this isn't Dunedin
Florida on Sunday what waters are you
swimming I'm swimming in the open waters
it all called the Gulf of Mexico
it's the Gulf yes and here you are
crossing the finish I am finishing the
run portion come on and you know
celebrating with your friends right here
is Who I am
we're happy to be finished and we had a
good time just your first triathlon rich
it's crazy half marathons marathons
triathlons I'm a very good cheerleader
though how many have you done
hahaha very good cheerless 5k all right
but in terms of a triumph no can't get
him why are you doing what are you get
on I enjoy the competition and it's a
great stress reliever you know when you
have a house full of kids yes you need
something and I look forward to getting
out and just running you take it out on
the ocean and a bike and on the road and
on the team and I'm ready to come back
home and be mom again and how what are
you trained how do you train what are
you doing I have just training running
on the trail usually every other day can
i bike and I enjoyed that
Tony bikes I love the bikes you guys
bike training together yeah that's
impressive there's no other way to put
it it's a heck of a car
Bushmen that really is look forward to
many more coming up I have one coming up
in September
well many in the NFL community are
trying to train me for my 40 I'll be
very honest I don't know if I wanna know
if I want a piece of this I don't know
if I'm cut out to get a piece of this
Lauren and Tony Dungy we chose you we'll
talk more about this book when we come
back here on the Rich Eisen show don't
you dare go anywhere for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app